Welcome everyone I hope you're all Ready
For This Next topic I think it's All
very Close To Our Hearts at least for
Myself I'll be Keeping extra attention
with this One Welcome Without further To
import full Focus f How to reduce stress
and pressure  as a data Scientist I'm
join Here Today by Martin Martin has his
own venture comode Where aims to helpies
with dealing
stressing
of let
welcome thank [
Applause]
you thank you very much for Being Here
I'm ma RM pool Yes How to reduce  stress
and pressure as a data specialist I
called it it's not Just the data
Engineers And The Scientist It's It It
people in general software Developers as
well
ehm the way that I see the world
evolving is that Technology is Getting
more and more complex business Amand is
Getting Higher and Higher especially on
data Products on Ai applications machine
learning There The Pressure as a
specialist to realize those ambitions
also increases at least That's What I
see in the companies worked with and
in So how do we Deal with
it How do you become resilient  because
It Will Be There and it will
somehow impact you but how will you be
resilient to Come Back from a stressful
Event That's What I try to explain stuff
about for today and also let you do and
Experience Some things yes
I'm A Little  Bit stressed right now and
Perhaps You Are Not but many people Look
At Me I have a dry Mouth so I really
Experience stress and That's Ok So what
I'm gna do I'm gna CAL Myself Down And
if you want to join you can  join It's
tool number one from the Learning so the
first tool Would Be and you're invited
to join You also invited not to join we
gna Breathe in for f Seconds so we gna
Do A Long in Breath we gna Hold Our
Breath for f Seconds  quickly Breathe out
in one Seconds And then wait Until
breathing starts Again only comfortable
with it you don't have to do it Breath
in for
Seconds hold one
two f quickly
exhale Stay empty You don't have to gas
Another Breath
Again This Is act  the one Breath
Break Room
iset
stress is
[Music]
dyers
technolog [
Music]
toes
iam work stress
Pressure
on the employer on the organizational 40
of the respond yeah There is a business
continuity Risk If You're In A smaller
Company like for example 10  People and
you only have two backenders If one one
of the backenders Drops Out because He
ill For Long Run You're probably screwed
Not just as coworker backend but also as
the Boss Of The Company Because you have
to fix Pretty Hard to fix Yes prevention
Pretty
important Lear learn Today and on the
right Side lower Right Side a lot of
improvement these Are The Numbers Of
Stuff is being done so There also a lot
of improvement in companies Where it's
not Being done yet some between 30 To %
This Is Not About  Current figures It's
More about the Trend The Big part
Sorry This Is Another nice example spac
Io devs Platform eh We Are winners as
data Engineers and data Scientist We the
best
Reason to
do few highlights but due to the time i
will Only go to the first  one heavy
workload insufficient skills leads to
stress That's interesting part I see
that Myself Experience Myself developer
as and the number five is also
interesting listening to music and
playing video games is a coping
Mechanism Yes under certain condition
number si also very interesting devops
It guys get  irritated I do I get cranky
stuff doesn't
work I plan to work or other people
around me don't do what they Do I you
noce noce for yourself A Little
Bit to much I'm G talk to you yes What is
stress What  is preventing you to have
full Focus on your work h full Focus
Being The Ability to have all your
attention all your
Energy doing available working on a
single task or a single Job or a single
Problem I see A relationship between
full Focus and stress They can  Come
Together but usually they like opposite
Po on a Spectrum eh but What is stress
Explain that to you and what does your
nervous system Inside Of Your Body have to
do with it not Just A Brain
Thing
Focus
ess stress helps prev Focus
Focus book by Stanley  Rosenberg It's One
Of The books I Had to read during My
trauma release exercise provider
training and certification And you see
the Brain Different part of Brain Being
colored and Red Line Over There Running
downs nervous vag The virus nerve but
for Here the Brain is designed in  a
certain way to help you deal with stress
and going back in the Brain design Back
In Time In Our Evolution We were at
least Our ancestors Buch of reptiles so
we moved Around The Earth very
instinctive so everything we did eating
Fighting Running Sleeping was based on
Instinct and Instinct driven over Time
We Found Out somehow or we evolved
towards a More like social Creature so
we needed to have Different skills or
the skills were There And then we did
the Behavior probably to have uh to have
memory Because We Need To Know Hey  I Met
him Yesterday Yesterday he was cool Okay
I'm Safe or I Met Sorry her Yesterday
She was really pissed off me ok Better
Avid you need memory to to Evolve to be
Safe in the social environment and the
the limbic Brain also gives a Layer
of social Sorry emotional Feeling and
emotional processing And then even More
Years later We Started to use Our and
Evolve Our Rational Brain so the
neocortex the latest shaped Brain part
and That's the part where we are able to
think about the logical
we J Da
solvent able  your own
Behavior That's Where we want to be as
data Scientist and data Engineers
People If we want to focus All Blood and
Oxygen and energies need to go to that
Brain Parts but we stress we to survive
bodies survive Mind Blood
stress
representation of Events that ur  but
they occur Around that can be Anything
Somebody Walking In that door and
starting to Yell like hell or with a
baseball bed running in that could Give
stress already but it's also Sitting
Here and Perhaps not understanding my
story
yet Yes or If We presented as a  that
analyst that SCI The Holy Grail of data
set For The Company The Customer the
best data please build me
Little Less hard
[Music]
AG normal situation So if an outlier
Event occurs Your Body responds to it
and It Just deals with it because It
wants  to survive and if you take that
One Step further eh Dr David
belli The Guy Who Made The Theory Method
he Said We Are Just an organism And I
Know we got a huge Brain as well but
we're an organism aimed for Survival and
That's It  so entire Body Mind hormones
nervous system muscles They work
Together we
survive pra also
reproduce Whatever is happening To Us
The Body or the organism will respond in
the perfect and most efficient
Manner that Sounds weird because Being
punched And then Getting really slow
really small to protect  yourself is
Perhaps Not The Best survival strategy
you think at least not the most Heroic
and not the most Rational ok thing to do
socially accepted but it is a coping
mechanism Your Body to survive the
stressful
Moment So What is a nervous system and w
approach  it briefly from a physiological
View but More from a functional View So
What does it do for you in relationship to
focus probably seen this graph Somewhere
In Your biology Class or at Middle
school Something This is the the
physiological View on it most important
Parts are the
peral system bl Lines to the
Ones like mot sensor
wires to get In
signals Heat Being
touched process Somewhere in the Central
nervous system in many occasions
Together with h using your Brains but in
a lot of a lot of instances It will not
even go to the  Brain It will be
processed somewhere
else There is a functional View on this
as well and That's the difference
between The controllable and the
autonomous View system Sorry Who can
give me an example of Something That's
happening to ours to US autonomous
automatically Yes breathing
happening automatic
weun  that
I in Mo
My
some
that the nervous System can be used the
controllable part and the Breath is
actually the best example of it to Both
accelerate or decer Your Body so to get
More stressed or Less stressed Get A
Very High stress State Back towards
acceptable  level or go back to recovery
mode second View Would Be This one al
of VI nervous system
[Music]
stress
symp symp syst is rest
parp Everybody ins Of Us nervous
Systems Hulk Bruce
Ban
we
also relaxed socially engaged Calm
analytical like Bruce Banner but that
depends  on the State of nervous system
and from that Point on It's The nervous
System Who has a certain filter how you
perceive stuff If Somebody would Fall
From The Ceiling Over There And You're
In A relaxed St listening to music you
oh Something Drop The Ceiling  Light BB
ok but if already in stress State It will be
like What's happening Over There proba
gna Curse towards
Little
exper work manager coming in Lot of
[ __ ] If stressed manager coming of
Bullit rela ok l
to sim
ex ok I'm if you want to  Again You don't
have to do Tiny breathing test me we are
able to use Our Breath to control Our
nervous
system and I want you [
Music]
to feel or Sorry to observe in Breath
can do that in two ways you can put
hands on Belly  chest Perhaps
Moving My thick Bre in my chest I to the
amount of in Breath If Bre in Count One
Bre
do as soon
as observe
Yes counting
in
Yes sit as comfortable as
toser hard because It Gets
Quiet distracted your brain If something
is Moving Perhaps Something  going on to
your Nose
Mouth
And then you can stop breathing
in One Ok You counted The amount of in
Breath You can multiply that by Because
We half minute like Count f Times you
make it Times e Times Raise your hand if
you have like More Than  15 Breath in a
minute e There
noad 10
[Music]
r
hak we More to the We Are Less relaxed
and we gna Go More into a Fight State So
You have the body Always going Whatever
Event is occurring through a temporary
freeze if the door Slam  clos I'm Like
What's happening Oh Nothing It's The
door so There Is Always an initial
freeze then we try to Fight stuff and if
that doesn't work out we gna flight we
Run Away
that even is ex bar People
punching free mode to protect  yourself
Feeling actually The sensations of the
pain And stuff
Yes yes Imagine like Walking In A bar Us
Big Guy pi Fight at least My experiences
If
In
Me start punching I'm Punch Back There
moment Where That's not G work I'm g t
Myself ne  chest h That's Why we chest
pain When little working behind the
computer Our neck is like really tense
in a stress situation we gna Fight for a
couple of Seconds and if that doesn't
work we gna ba Out Yes but anyhow Your
Body will do this  either to Fight or to
flight do flight Mo Ja and the Beauty of
it it's a perfect response is is all
done by ne done instantly very Little to
control
recover Part Of Your Body changes under
stress
Idea legs Ja ver
mus Shoulders very
good
interesting Con Do  I'm angry This Is A
Very Good perception If You're at work
and you feel like a tense Muscle Just Go
observe yourself If You're already A
Little Bit stressed a good One Because
In The Past as a reptile we had to Chew
On Our opponent we didn't have a lot of
legs or weapons Ja Shoulders Eyes If he
Is Now starting a fight with me I'm Only
focusing On You I want to I want to pick
on you and I Don't Care Who's in  the
room anymore but if I'm if I'm relaxed
if I'm rest and diges I'm gna be social
Again and I'm able To Look at 20
soon
More
tours
Little bri
wep system we fighting thereby Our Heart
Is hè  What do we do If We start running
What happens to Our Heart
weight Goes up Indeed Yes so Running eh
voluntary at least as a sport Healthy
Thing There is more Demand in
eh in energy and Oxygen needed so The
Heart Will start Pumping quicker Long
Movement will  be bigger and we don't
need Our digestive system because we're
gonna Run but if We Do It Long Enough we
need to recover Again and That's Why we
want to also Go Back to the rest and
part State That's Where Our dig Comes up
Again we G Get nutritions Out Of Body
recover The muscles Whatever is needed
that means that Our Heart can go Down
breathing also Go
Down All Our organs have Sor The
Majority of our organs have like two
functional also two States to be contr
on also two States  to operate in and
That's interesting thing and my Take
This Is yeah it's cool to be on the
stress Side Work Hard SP Hard afters to
rid of all the things in head are
organism
Body
stresses Sitting Down bench doing
Nothing not even
television rest because television stuff
My Playing games Looking At enre
Body game in
mie
so Fight flight is a good
proactive stressful in a good Sense Way
but not All The
Time Oh sorry Okay we're gna do the
Breath test Again but first I'm Gonna
Give You A Few  breathing rounds If
You're ok with it If You're pregnant if
you have a heart disease or an Aras
Don't join and if you don't like it
halfway Just quit and Catch on your
regular Breath Again
Yes I'm gna  ask you to do the box
breathing It's breathing Method from
biathlon and also from Navy seals Where
We Do Four second Inhale we're gna Hold
Our lungs full for f Seconds and a f
second exhale And then we gna Stay empty
so not breathing Again directly f
Seconds in Hold exhale Hold Ja Give It A
Try It's a way to youl observe what it
does I'm not gna Explain it from the
beginning ja
ok it in CH Little To The Front of
Chair
[Music]
rela two three four  empty two three four
in two three f Hold two three f Out two
three f empty two three f in continue
for yourself very
good
Hold out
empty very
good
in
Hold
out and Stay
empty n six counts in in two three f
Five Six Hold two three  f f si empty Out
3 f f si and Stay empty two 3 f f si in
two three f f si Hold two 3 f f si emp
two 3 f f si ok
Count your in Breath Again either Feel
your chest in your Belly or just observe
in two one
start Just  notice and Count If breathing
in g Count breathing out you don't
Count
A Few More Seconds Keep Focus on your
breathing try to observe it If It
doesn't work It doesn't work for today
It Doesn't
Matter Two One and stop  breathing Okay
Raise your hands If You Had More Than 15
Breath Sorry multiply The number that
you just counted by two someone Who had
More Than 15 Breath in a minute 15 Yes 10
to 15 Okay f to 10 Okay Less than
f Yes Less than
two Oh  sorry There is one Okay Who had
Less breathing Now than When We Did This
test originally yes very good okay Good so
That's what you do conscious breathing
calming
Down Yes skip Next
One
Yes so we Had A few nice marketing Trends
you know data For The Good  Ai For The
Good and it's I think The intention is
good but it was used for marketing
mainly at least That's How I perceived
It My World I'm In Perhaps
Somewhere I did Something bad on the
PowerPoint Let's use stress For The Good
actually
Focus SO
summing How can we use this stress eh
This Was calming Down I'm not going to do
the the speeding up part Because We G we
can accelerate Our Body as well we can
do that after the workshop so People can
go to the Keynote or Stay Here  and we
gna Do It In A Little In A smaller
session That's also possible but makey
for Now is prevent continuous stress and
use your
Breath to reduce your stress level If
You control your Breath and you slow It
Down h extending The aale What We Just
did  you notice A few minutes at least
The Majority of you do that You're
Getting calmer Heart Is Going Down
breathing is going
down Take some organism idle time SO
instead of Only working Make sure that
rest do Go Walking go to Forest yoga
Works like h  breathing sessions work
meditate Works h Make sure that your
Brains and nervous System aot of
triggers Thing
breathing
observing that part actually helps help
coworker in meting is ex Some People do
unen to
them calmer environment foren Aka Take
Them Out Of The meeting and let Them
relax  A Little Bit and Walk a little bit
Around Yes that helps thereby you prevent
each other from tipping off Falling into
Bed and Being out on The Long Run and
The Last is probably the most
important use stress or Focus to code
and code like hell to create  Great
Solutions for the world for the people
that you love and Just keep on doing
What you're doing but then in a More
efficient Way Thank you very much for
[Applause]
attention